für den inhalt dieses spots sind alle
parteien verantwortlich für die familie
besuchen sagt es wird einfach sein
scheint er ganz bleaching der premiere
betreuungsgeld geben wir geld zu
brauchen wir frauen bekommen sollten
heute schmerzensgeld er ganz wichtig
dass solche verheiratete ohne kinder
warum eine frau geheiratet hat bestimmt
nicht damit bettina mit dem jährlich die
cdu gerne ganz wichtig egal ich
wiederhole es profitieren verheiratete
oder kinder die alleine ziehen das
kindle fire die kita gehen wir kriegen
einfach in die kapelle verachten oder
weiter hoffe ich kann mein kleiner
besitzer
obama begrüßte heute da wo sie ihre
fahrer beschlossen nachdem sie 30
maßnahmen ist es endlich soweit
wieso ging jetzt wird sich dort aus
schnell ja ich sag's euch weil dem der
autor grundeis geht im september wird
gewählt
noch vor einer woche sache ganz anders
aus
alle parteien im bundestag waren für die
er für allein nur die cdu tanzt auf
freie
die waren zwar gegen die diskriminierung
gleichgeschlechtlicher
lebenspartnerschaften sagt man da hin zu
eher für alle ja sowas gibt es gibt
leute die sind generell gegen pornos
gucken ja trotzdem haben wir mein
nachbar gesagt und mit stroh weil die
gräber schönborn rege mich dass die
vorfahren kann man sagt die wohl noch
senken
zu einer spa karmann gmbh fdp stemmt
sich gegen den trend zur beschaffung
manche deutsche so anguckt wie ganz froh
wenn ich irgendein abklappen bauch
können abgesehen auch familienpolitik in
der politik seine große liebe die wählen
soll
aber so keiner waren habe ich mich nicht
dafür interessiert wie die arbeiter weiß
wohin muss die mir dessen wir ein
wahllokal am tag ist eine stammkneipe
[Musik]
für den inhalt dieses spots sind alle
parteien verantwortlich